[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof i'm martin smith and
walter fight hi martin hi walter are you
doing well well the world is in
uproar so we must be doing fine no we're
still going on
let's open with a word of prayer
our heavenly father
we
we have these
discussions and it's a little bit of a
break in between the chaos in the world
so enlighten our minds help the
discussion and bless us in jesus name
amen amen
martin there are so many people who want
to talk about russia
ukraine is this a north-south issue of
daniel
and
we've been
watching the situation for some time
but
you know we didn't want to jump right in
and jump to confusions yeah we would
prefer some conclusions
so
let's look at it and let's approach it
carefully and try and see if we can fit
it into the prophetic picture
because
this is something that concerns people
yes and there's a lot of voices out
there with different scenarios and
putting it together but yes so nobody i
think has an absolute answer so let's
not be arrogant about this
let us be open to
ideas suggestions
and
look at it with a cool mind
yes because
we're not
out there to say that we know everything
no absolutely not
we're all on a road and we're looking
through a glass darkly exactly
well here's a statement to start off
with the world is stirred with the
spirit of war the world is stirred with
the spirit of war the prophecy of the
eleventh chapter of daniel has nearly
reached its complete fulfillment
soon the scenes of trouble spoken of
in the prophecies will take place
now
this was written quite a while ago of
course
but
nevertheless
the prophecies of the final events of
daniel 11 were still future
yes and we're living in that future
so it's good to look at it again and
again
i have given some lectures on it in the
past and i haven't really
changed my mind greatly about it
but
we must look at it and see whether we
can expand or improve oh we've even done
a few um episodes
two years ago on this subject as well on
the north south issue south issue and
it's important and still while we're
doing this discussion as well
like you said to keep an open mind
because it's not cast in stone yet no
nothing is cast in stone
and this statement from testimonies
volume 1 page 268 i was shown the
inhabitants of the earth in the utmost
confusion
war bloodshed privation want famine
pestilence were brought in the land
we do have have all of these recipes for
this cake don't we yep
my attention was then called from the
scene there seemed to be a little time
of peace
once more the inhabitants of the earth
were presented before me and again
everything was in the utmost confusion
strife war bloodshed famine pestilence
raged everywhere
is this a possibility that we're talking
about the world wars and then a final
conflict
well
if that is the case the scenario fits
the scenario fits and we move from
the second world war which was a world
war but really it was very localized yes
europe
and maybe japan and a little bit in
america but a little bit here a little
bit there
but here it says everywhere
that's a big word
other nations were engaged in this war
and confusion so that puts it beyond the
shadow of doubt that you know it's not
just a european issue
etc it is a universal issue
war caused famine want and bloodshed
caused
pestilence and then men's heart failed
them for fear and for looking after
those things which were coming on the
earth
and what what makes people
afraid
something that they don't know and
something that looks so ominous that
survival seems a remote possibility
and uh would would uh pestilence qualify
yes would a nuclear war qualify
definitely
okay and the even the threat of nuclear
war
is already giving that fear now i find
it interesting that the bible in matthew
speaks about rumors of war and rumors of
war seem to be a very prominent feature
right it is and it's casting fear the
whole time yes so there is war but the
rumor of war is the one that is casting
the fear it's it's almost as if it's
worse off in the beginning because
eventually when it happens
it's almost as if the rumors have
desensitized you
all right so let's just look at a few
verses here
from daniel 11 because that was our
introduction that this prophecy is going
into fulfillment
so the king of the north versus the king
of the south now we're actually not
living in these verses right here we're
living a little bit later we'll come to
those verses
that come after these but there's an
interesting or very important
principle that we find here
namely that both of these kings the king
of the north and the king of the south
hearts shall be to do mischief
and they shall speak lies at one table
that's a very important clue
very important
you cannot take this away because you're
gonna
fall into a trap
if you don't
adhere or listen or take attentive
attention
to this spot so here we have two
adversaries
and they're speaking lies
and they're speaking lies at one table
so there appear to be
adversaries but they're actually sitting
at one table
so the populace is being fooled
now this you would call a conspiracy
theory
but this is a biblical
conspiracy theory of biblical
proportions
all right what happens then
but it shall not prosper
what shall not prosper obviously the
mischief plans the plan
shall not prosper although they might
appear to prosper
for yet the end shall be at the time
appointed in other words they will lose
their power can we assume
that this is a global game
where people are being lied to
by two supposedly opposite parties that
sit at the same table yes
how would you arrange that wouldn't you
say that secrecy is of the utmost
importance
everything has to happen in darkness and
only what they want you to see is up
in the open air so you think secret
societies will be involved
we have many statements in the spirit of
prophecy that they are involved and that
we should have nothing to do with them
right
so people that say this is a conspiracy
will really have to do some explaining
because this is very conspiratorial
now we need to find out what this
mischief is
and why the sharad why
obviously the sharad is to get the
mindset of the people through the lies
attuned to a particular plan
and that particular plan involves
mischief
yes the seat
yes all right
so at the time appointed he shall return
and come towards the south but it shall
not be as the former or as the latter
we're dealing with a historic issue
but this prophecy also has a future
fulfillment as we saw in that quote from
the spirit of prophecy
just like matthew 24 had a then time
future fulfillment
now
what is the story here for the ships of
kitim
shall come against him therefore he
shall be grieved and return and have
indignation against the holy covenant
and so shall he do
he shall even return and have
intelligence with them
that forsake
the holy covenant
this is a very serious issue
so
the ships of kitim
does that imply
that economic issues will be paramount
yes
definitely it will be in turmoil it'll
be in turmoil there will be a economic
oppressive
condition
that will cause people to or
the powers that be
to come to some kind of conformity so
that they can perform mischief
but it's very important that the
mischief is against the holy covenant
this is not only a worldly or secular
occurrence
this is a
religious thing as well all right so
there's a religious connotation
and the ones who are involved in the
mischief are those
that have forsaken the holy covenant
so would you imagine that the antichrist
would fit
very well into that picture definitely i
think he will be the leader he will be
the kingpin right because he's the
master
of uh
those that have forsaken the holy
covenant he is called the
antichrist all right
so let's unpack it a little further and
arms shall stand in his part
and they shall pollute the sanctuary of
strength
and shall take away the daily let's just
call it daily
for they shall place the abomination
that makes desolate
so we have a very religious
aspect here
arms shall stand in his part he has
military power behind him
he controls military power
modern i have a question
if they're all sitting at one table
do you think that he might control both
sides of the military power i'm sure he
does
does this sound like a logical
conclusion yes
okay
that would be very intriguing and very
conspiratorial and i'm sure some will
shout conspiracy
but this is what it says here right
exactly okay so
he has arms that stand on his part
now how is he using that
power that he has
he's using it
to pollute the sanctuary
of strength
now we've dealt with the sanctuary the
sanctuary basically is the plan of
salvation in type
that was the heavenly one and then the
earthly one showing towards what christ
will do all right so if he pollutes the
sanctuary then he is polluting the plan
of salvation
he's putting something in the place of
jesus christ
and he is diverting the attention from
the plan of salvation into
some other thing
could it be something like social
justice for example
now what does that all entail
uh he shall take away
the daily
now we can have a long discussion on the
daily
because sacrifice is added in the
original
now some claimed that this was a
reference to pagan rome being removed
and then papal rome coming in
to power be that others let's not get
too involved in the daily otherwise
we'll digress here
but
whatever it is that they're doing here
they will get to the point where they
place the abomination that makes
desolate yes now what is that
that was the roman standard
that was placed around jerusalem
right
it was a pagan standard
and it was the
pagan standard of their power and their
authority
does the papacy
the antichrist system claimed to have a
standard of its power and authority yes
sunday sunday
they say it quite clearly they say it is
a mark
the fact that we've moved the solemnity
from the seventh day sabbath to the
first day of the week sunday is a mark
of our
ecclesiastical power yeah
if you want to know the strength of
anybody they have the sign or they have
this one thing that shows it and that is
the one thing that shows that the roman
catholic system has its authority and
power and once the world accepts that
authority of the roman system
then they will have polluted the
sanctuary because they would have put a
man
who claims apostolic succession
in the place of jesus christ
and he is the one that hands out
salvation through his sacramental acts
and by putting his fingers in the
so-called
treasury of merit
now we've dealt with that in previous
what's up so we're not going to deal
with it so the bottom line is
the king of the north and the king of
the south sit at the same table
they plan
mischief
and they speak lies
and a mischief is with those who forsake
the holy covenant
and they will use military power to get
what they want
and they shall take away the daily
and they shall place
their mark of authority
in the place of god's mark of authority
so this is a religious issue
that brings us now
to what's happening between russia and
the ukraine because there are some that
feel
that russia having been and still being
a communist country
is king of the south yes
because it's not really religious
correct
then you have
the king of the north who happens to be
the papacy
now
this is how the pioneers
saw it that the king of the north was
the papacy
and obviously
when you read for example the book of
jeremiah
where the enemy comes from the north it
was always a reference to babylon and
the priest and the king of babylon
he
was the one that you had to bow down to
yes
now he was the pontifex maximus
later in history when the media persians
took over
this priesthood fled to pergamum
and there it was established and this
title of pontifex maximus was then
transferred to the roman emperor as a
gift by the last king
of pergamum who was atalus iii
and then this gift was kept but he had
to have
certain
criteria and one of them was that he had
to be worshipped as god
and julius caesar is the first one who
took that title
and the power to be worshipped as a god
and since then the caesars were gods now
who has that title pontifex maximus
today the pope
the pope so he is the roman heir
of that title
now this is arrogance of the highest
order he is the king of babylon in other
words
you can even see the acknowledgement of
it in his twitter account
at
his pontifex
account name so he is taking that up on
himself he's taking that title upon
himself so we cannot divorce him from
the equation
now we know that the
counter-reformation has placed many
different antichrists or future
antichrists that are supposedly not here
into the picture but that's not the
reformation view it never was and it's
not an advent view either correct and it
doesn't actually fit in the biblical
view
and you can't change history
so martin let's just look at what some
people are saying about this ukrainian
situation
and it's so interesting
that involved in the so many celebrities
beauty queens
uh
actors
so let's have a look what
this ukrainian
parliament member had to say
i'm saying here along with my crew we
are members of the resistance and we are
armed so when you are saying she says
that she is armed and ready to fight i'm
not only saying this we are proving this
actually by our actions so ukraine right
now resisting very hard putin is not
getting any wins of what he wanted and
for now it's 4
300 russian soldiers are being killed on
ukrainian soil so i think it's like a
pretty bad result for a dictator right i
think if those numbers are accurate this
is obviously not what putin expected so
far uh for the rest of us that aren't
ukrainians i think the world quite
frankly kyra is surprised by the will of
the ukrainian people to stand up and
fight are you
well i'm not surprised i we have been
fighting
putin for the last eight years and we
had three revolutions in our country
when we did not agree with what was
going on with
the direction of where we're moving in
but right now it's a critical time
because we know that we not only fight
for ukraine we fight for this new world
order for the democratic countries we
knew that we are the shield for the
europe we knew that we are protecting
not only ukraine we are protecting like
all the other countries that would be
next if we fail that's why we just
cannot fail
do you predict ukrainian victory over
russia in this invasion
absolutely i have no other scenarios in
my head i see people i see women like me
bearing arms and standing up to protect
their families their cities and their
countries there is no force in the world
that could actually
destroy us
well martin
there were some interesting things that
she said they're not only fighting for
ukraine
they're fighting for the new world order
yeah and these democratic countries
that make up probably nato
and all of this
and what was interesting for me is
the part of the resistance
this is all sounds so
dystopian movie-like
and
i'm not trying to say that there's it's
not bad in anything but the way that
this was
portrayed on here
there's a few things that's a little bit
hard for me to
to
swallow
well she said
literally thousands of russian troops
have been killed thus far
and this mighty war machine
of russia
cannot crush this little country in a
few days
that is a very strange scenario
and uh they believe that they will have
victory they're practicing with the
wooden guns
and
there's a lot of talk about all the
wooden guns and
some people say this is all
fake there's no doubt that there's
turmoil in ukraine there's no doubt that
there are terrible situations
but whether the media is telling us the
truth
that is another story you see that's why
i'm trying to say this because we don't
want to come
um over as unsympathetic no no that's
the last thing i want to do i really
sympathize for all and it's not a good
thing that there's ever war
just like you said
we have to look through
the bigger picture and just put it into
perspective so if we look at the
prophetic picture
here in the end
there is going to be a clash it is a
north south clash
but they're sitting at the same table
and they're planning mischief together
with those that are against the holy
covenant we know who they are and the
mischief
in involves deceit and that will
propaganda will fall part of that
absolutely all right
now
what is the agenda here you know many
people believe
that
russia together with communist china
that they
portray
absolutely the king of the south
because that is
communism it's atheism
and that is what they stand for
then the west they stand with the king
of the north this is the idea that is
out there and with that the king of the
north stands for morality and the king
of the self for immorality now that
picture to me martin
does not fit no and i'll tell you why
because in the type in the original
there were two literal parties the one
was literal babylon
that stood for the religio political
system
and that literal babylon was against the
king of the south that stood for literal
egypt
once you move into the spiritual realm
you cannot apply physical nations to the
prophetic picture and the book of
revelation in chapter 11 makes it quite
clear when it says spiritually egypt yes
when this power that comes up from the
bottomless pit
this final conglomerate
which belongs to this terrible beast
that has never changed its colors really
when that comes up and rules
then there's this supposed clash with a
spiritual king of the south
so we're dealing with a mindset we're
not dealing with nations
now once you make it nations then your
eyes are looking in a particular
geographic area
and the religious world is doing exactly
that and we will show some videos of
what the religious world believes
they believe this is all heading for a
war with israel yeah
because that is the prophetic picture
that they have which comes from futurism
which is based on lies in fact
jesuitical lies mischief mischief so
let's try and get that out of our
picture and say we're not dealing with
countries
we're dealing with mindsets
in the middle ages
who controlled morality
the papacy
absolutely the papacy rigidly did they
use the secular power to enforce their
morality yes
yes state had to enforce it since the
french revolution
did they lose that capacity to use the
state to enforce their morality yes
it was called a mortal wound that's it
all right
so they lost that power but the mortal
wound will be
healed
now martin
the secularism
is it
confined to nations
or is it present in all nations it's
in all nations aha definitely
this king of the north mentality that we
want morality to be controlled by a
particular entity call it the church
is that in all nations
yes
even in communist china exactly
isn't the church
underground
but very active in china yes
isn't the church
active in russia
definitely very active isn't the church
active in the ukraine yes very much so
right
so you cannot say there is the enemy and
here is the friend
it is it is more diffused than that
we're dealing
with
a mindset we're dealing with two
ideologies that are going to clash here
the one they call the king of the north
ideology
which is the religio political system
enforcing morality
a particular kind
under a particular authority
namely that of the papacy
and then you have the secularism now if
you take
joe biden
is a roman catholic
so you would call him a king of the
north adherent yes
does he have very secular
non-king of the north ideologies correct
non-moral he's got some that's going
contrary to what the actual king of the
north
sees as moral all right so
is there a confusion because he's
actually
comprising both king of the north
attributes and king of the south
attributes yes
the bottom line is one of the mindsets
must go
okay now she says they're fighting for
ukraine
but they're fighting for the new world
order
now let's put that into perspective
everybody is so afraid of the new world
order
what is the new world order
all right it has it has many components
it has economic components
definitely economic components
but the new world order
comprises giving the power of the state
back to the church that's it
that is the new world order because the
bible says the kings of the world
will give their power unto the beast was
that power removed after the french
revolution yes
will they give it back yes yes
so
let's look at it from that perspective
and that sort of sets
the stage for
a discussion
now martin has a speech
by
putin
and it's a very interesting speech
because it sounds more if the king of
the north is speaking then the king of
the south is speaking right yes
now does this man have
nuclear capabilities
according to every all data yes yes so
his finger is on the button
has he been uh quite vocal about it yes
has he even threatened with it he said
that if anybody goes against him they'll
have
more trouble than they've ever been in
history
all right so
does this create fear
for a possible third world war yes okay
so let's listen to this speech and see
what we can glean
to national identity is related to the
global development
here they are related to moral and
geopolitical aspects we witness
many euro-atlantic
countries
are refusing forgetting their
roots including the valleys of
christianity which form the basis of the
civilization they are renouncing any
ethical
basis
any identity national religious or even
gender ones they are following the
policy which equals
families with many children and
one gender families excesses of
political correctness leaders when the
parties
pursue propaganda of pedophilia
representatives in many western
countries are afraid of mentioning their
gender they even
are canceling some festivities and they
are hiding
uh
the basis of such
festivities and they are trying to
impose this model to anyone i am
convinced
this lead leads us to degradation and
primitivization
to deep
moral crisis
[Music]
martin that was a moral speech
does the papacy
have an agenda
to
make the family the core of its moral
issues no definitely that's one of their
main that that and the poor
is their main focus
social justice
and the family
one of the issues around the family
is
time to rest and to communicate with one
another it's necessary for your health
it's necessary for your religious
experience it's necessary for your
social experience
it's absolutely necessary that the
family forms the core again
of
the base for all morality
that's it that's a biblical issue
does he sound like a king of the north
proponent or a king of the south
profound proponent definitely king of
the north i think he actually sounds
more king of the north than some that we
relate to king of the north ah
so
if we divorce the countries now as we
have said and we're looking at
ideologies
then you can see that what he is saying
is that we
as russia
are not prepared to accept the liberal
agenda of the world that's it is that
what he's saying that's exactly what
he's saying okay let me repeat that he's
saying
we as russia
are not prepared to accept the liberal
agenda of the world where everything
goes transgenderism
destruction of the family moral values
we will have no part in it is that what
he's saying yes okay
now who does he see
as the powers that are introducing this
liberal agenda the ones that acts
actually supposed to defend it the waste
so he's referring to the united states
he's referring to europe yes he's
actually said the christian countries
have forgotten the christianity the
christian countries have forgotten their
christianity and these countries
are trying to expand
and put their power base even into
ukraine where they will then have their
atomic weapons on his doorstep and he
uses this as a
as a weapon
a political weapon to say
well if america didn't want missiles in
cuba i have the same right to say i
don't want missiles in ukraine and if
ukraine says i'm going to join nato i'll
take you out yeah
that's exactly what he's saying but
martin they're sitting at the same table
and they're talking mischief
you see the problem is
exactly what he said is what the
antichrist system the papacy is also
propagating
all right now
let's just think about this a little bit
but
we're just speculating right
but let us put it this way
there is the threat of this escalating
into a nuclear war does anyone want to
have that no
no
because that would mean the destruction
of millions and millions of lives right
so there is this terrible threat that is
associated
now with a religious model dilemma
who is the mediator who is being called
to mediate in this conflict
the pope
it seems as if you cannot divorce him
from the system right you cannot
because the bible tells us you cannot
in the end especially that verse that
says
they're sitting at the same all right so
this mindset
that the model issue which is also
associated with the papacy
although by the way
the papacy doesn't have a very good
track record when it comes to morality
does it no
but
at least in their words they have these
sweet words right about the family and
all of these things
there are many many in the world that do
not want to go along with any form of
religious mindset there are many living
in china there are many living in
the western world
all over the world that have that
mindset but that mindset has to go
would it be a useful thing to use even
the fear of nuclear war to let it go no
they'll use any means any means
all right
he has arms
doesn't it say it in the bible
so he has military power at his command
is it only one side or both sides of the
military power that he has at his
command could he play them up against
each other yes
is this happening at the moment
i think it is now what martin
if the russia says
i will not accept the western mindset
and i'm prepared to push the button
to prevent it
what if fear drives humanity to the
point of compromise and says
let's
give the moral
values of the papacy a chance
putin would you accept that
and
you know what the problem the problem
that i see is
it sounds good
because it sounds biblical and it could
prevent war and how would it look if
anyone wants to go against prohibiting
war
and even it's got moral values attached
to it all right so
even those in the west that are opposed
to the union of church and state
if it can prevent this holocaust
wouldn't it be wise to give this power a
chance after all this power
portrays itself as so concerned about
the poor
uplifting the downtrodden
and all it wants is to give the family
its place back and
they don't realize that he's working
against the holy covenant and setting up
the abomination of desolation namely his
moral authority over and against god's
moral authority is that a possibility is
and now you've put into the mix
patriotism
so
they a lot of people will
support this also because if you're
patriot
you understand that this is also
morality in this patriarch patriotism
that they export now it's interesting to
me that russia is the one in the fray at
the moment because russia is a religious
country yeah
all right it had enforced atheism on it
for
decades
but the orthodox church came out on top
but the orthodox church only came out on
top
once it had reached an agreement with
the papers yeah
because communism
is a papal invention
it was invented
by the jesuits practiced in great detail
in their reductions in south america and
then introduced via
their agents karl marx and all of those
associated with him and introduced into
the bolshevik revolution and you can
actually deduce from what he said
that he is against what the bolsheviks
and the whole communism
era
had portrayed okay
now martin
also important is that the ships of
chittim or kitim
involved the economics
again can you separate it absolutely and
say the economic power is only with the
west and not with not with the others
not at all because they can also form a
very powerful economic especially now
you cannot say that china is not a
powerful economic entity all right so
let's have a look whether they could
perhaps be sitting at the same table
and i have to say
when i mention our names like mrs merkel
even vladimir putin and so on say all
have been young global leaders of the
world economic forum
but
what we are very proud of now as a young
generation like prime minister trudeau
um president of brazil of argentina and
so on
that we penetrate the cabinets
so yesterday i was in a research at the
reception for prime minister
and
i
would know that
half of this cabinet or even more half
of
half of this cabinet are for our
actually young global leaders of the
verdict
and that's true in argentina too wow
yeah sorry that's true in argentina as
well it's through in argentina and it's
through in france no army mr president
who is a
young global leader but
sir martin he mentioned putin as
one of the team
yes so they're sitting at one table
france macron trudeau
he mentioned them all if you want to
have orto of cow you must always have an
enemy
even if it is a perceived enemy
so
now at the current moment russia is the
great enemy
maybe in the near future when they need
another one china can be a very useful
substitute as the enemy
but the idea is to create the order that
they want which is the new
economic
model
order
where the power is given unto the beast
has the papacy spoken
to all
of the major economic
uh people in the world definitely and
organizations cop 26
all the cop meetings has it got the
religious world in the bag through the
economical movement
is it playing the political
game
absolutely in a masterly fashion oh
perfectly okay
so if we look at this article here it
states that russian president vladimir
putin meets with the world economic
forum chairman klaus schwab that was in
and russian president president vladimir
putin met with the world economic forum
executive chairman klaus schwab in saint
petersburg
and
this is what was said we have always
maintained relations with your forum
that you found it and we will continue
to support it
of course russian representatives have
always taken part and will take part in
the events you hold for our part we are
holding similar events which of course
aim to establish business contacts with
russia's partners
above all else you know we are holding
the saint petersburg economic forum here
in saint petersburg
as well as in the far east in siberia
and in southern russia putin said is
there a close link definitely you know
because there's a lot of speculation
that putin couldn't be have been part of
the young
global leaders
all right but here he acknowledges
that they have been always been and are
still part of this world they're coming
up very well
now
if this is a game sitting at the same
table to get the world
out of fear of nuclear conflict to
eventually
embrace
the moral
superiority of the papacy then the kings
of the world will be giving their power
unto the beast right
is that a prophetic picture
that in view of our short chronology
time frame
would have to happen more or less now
yes
and it will have to happen relatively
fast
the last events will be rapid ones rapid
ones we've just moved from a major
calamity
into the next calamity exactly
now let's have a look at the other role
player namely zelinski
what is this picture at the top here
it's the world economic forum
where the ships of kitten very active
here
so here we have a profile
on the website of the world economic
forum of zelensky
so here it says that he's an actor he's
a screenwriter he's a creative director
a stand-up comedy contest team quarter
he played the lead role in the servant
of the people tv series that won the
world fest remy award usa 2016
and made the comedy film finalist short
list of the seoul international drama
awards south korea
the servant of the people also won the
intermedia globe silver award in the
entertainment tv show category at the
world media festival in hamburg germany
but did he get uh
pretty universal exposure yes he is
actually a very well known and popular
actor
so did they raise his profile oh
definitely he became well you can call
it an idol now martin
when we look at politics do actors play
a lot role no
for a very long time already i mean
reagan was an actor yeah john paul ii
the pope was an actor didn't the present
pope also play in movies
all jesuits are trained in jesuit
theater after all it's part of their
game
they believe
what
the supposed shakespeare wrote all the
all the world's a stage and all the men
and women merely players
all right
on the 21st of april 2019 he won the
regular election with 73.22
of the vote and on may 20 2019 was sworn
in as president of the ukraine
so if they're all involved with the
world economic forum and putin is also
involved do they all know each other
very well
i'm sure they do
are they perhaps sitting at the same
table
well they're sitting at the same world
economic forum table
how does the world portray
the issue at the moment they're
portraying zelinski
as
this hero
who has his military gear on who has his
bulletproof vest on and he's the one
fighting in the street keeping away
this big monster which is called russia
yeah
i believe if russia really wanted to it
would take
two or three days and they would have it
in the bag right
but they're dragging this out
all the world's a stage and all the men
and women merely players
we have to look not at the event
horrendous as it may be
because the jesuits say
that the ends justify the means even if
it means a lot of collateral damage
and that means even if there's a lot of
people that has to die all right now
what if we have heard in the media
now what did that verse say
are they speaking truth or are they
speaking lies lies all right
so the verse says that there was a crack
team that was sent to assassinate him
but he was foiled
so he's being played up as the hero yeah
how much is truth and how much his lies
we will only one day know we will one
way no yes and if you take the video
that we've shown first um about that
parliament member yes and this the
beauty queen that's
armed and ready and fighting it's a lot
of hype
to he to
portray them as heroes and you only hear
a one-sided set of heroes the other one
is they're trying to portray putin as
the stoic
sitting in his office with his stern
face etc etc
but
the bible tells me that the end game is
based on lies
it's interesting i was trying to search
for some
comments or any news
of the putin side and there's none you
cannot find any there's nothing i i'm in
i have been contact with a person that's
in russia
and most of the correspondents like have
been are they shutting down these things
so you don't hear the other side it
sounds a lot like
the
pandemic situation well you only hear
one side of the story because that's the
scenario that everybody has to be fed
all right so let's just make sure here
we have many pictures of putin and the
papacy and it goes back in history
because he was even involved in with the
previous popes right and all the way
back to
john paul ii john paul ii all the way
back and he's a very devout man because
look at what he's doing right here
that's something
that shows a certain kind of devotion
that is
not of an ordinary kind
so
we cannot in my opinion
place this man squarely
in the king of the south category not at
all he's playing a game
in order to get
the mindset of the world
to accept the moral authority of the
pope
let's look further
what about the other side
are they also associated with the pope
let's read president zielinski said on
twitter
thanked francis at pontifex for praying
for peace in ukraine and a ceasefire the
ukrainian people feel the spiritual
support of his holiness
both of them
sitting at the same table martin
is this evidence or is this conspiracy
and
if you take it into the biblical
timeline
right at the end
both
are associated
with the papacy
here is the religious news service from
february 27 2022 pope francis calls
ukrainian president zielinski to express
profound pain
in a tweet saturday the ukrainian
embassy to the holy see said during the
phone call pope francis voiced his most
profound pain
for the tragic events unfolding in the
country
the way in which they portray the pope
as this extremely
concerned
model
leader of the world
it's the latest effort made by the
vatican to show support and mediate
peace in the ukraine
now did he speak with the other side
yes
as ukraine bleeds pope francis and
russian patriarch kirill could be
negotiators is this the church
that's it in negotiating with the state
martin if the church starts negotiating
with the state
and succeeds in brokering
a ceasefire of any kind
is the moral position of the church then
elevated in the eyes of humanity
definitely
could it perhaps even go so far
as to prevent nuclear war if only this
model authority received a little more
recognition we've been at this before
when reagan and pope john paul
spoke to gorbachev
and if you go back to the quote of the
spirit of prophecy it said
it was this bad situation war everything
then relative peace
and we are at it again we're at it again
we've had a period of the so-called
relative peace but now we're at it again
i also find the timing very interesting
immediately after one crisis
of a medical nature
a health nature we're going into a
political crisis that could lead to a
spiritual elevation yeah it's amazing
and if you take it would this have
happened during the crisis the medical
crisis it would have would not have
worked right
all right so biden versus putin portends
the non-negotiable collision course we
are now witnessing unless something
truly extraordinary takes place
so they're living in a time of lent
this time of 40 days fasting
this is very interesting
which
is supposed to commemorate the
experience in the wilderness
now jesus did that fast for us and he
didn't expect us to repeat it
so this is a very
let me put it bluntly
paganized way of dealing with it because
it adds your own element of works to
already completed work that christ
achieved for you right yeah it's similar
to
what luther had to do in whipping
himself and that yes let's read this
sentence again because it's very
important
biden versus putin
potence the
non-negotiable collision course
we are now witnessing
in other words there needs to be a
mediator
so the king of the south mentality
which is very strong in biden
has come up against a king of the north
mentality
portrayed strangely by putin
and it is non-negotiable and it has a
military connotation because ukraine is
in the fray
and the western nato powers versus this
other
power block
in other words you cannot in this
situation
apply the label king of the north king
of the south to a country or political
grouping exactly also not a person it is
a mindset that must be conquered
and it is interesting that these two
mindsets
are in a clash now unless something
truly extraordinary takes place
and that will be a mind shift that's it
a mind shift
in 2016 pope francis became the first
catholic pontiff to meet a russian
patriarch traveling to cuba
to meet the person he called his brother
ecomenism had brought them together at
first they were at loggerheads
and we know that the rift between the
orthodox church
and the catholic church
comes over millennia
so this has been resolved
so there is no
conflict at the level of the church no
isn't it interesting if you just take
for instance
this pope francis
what is managed in that area
of the different religions even with the
grand imam
all of this
he's the biggest peacemaker
that this world has ever seen yes i saw
a video
many years ago
of
the
orthodox patriarchs coming into the
vatican and every single one of them
bowing down and kissing the ring of the
pope
now so that has already been achieved
so the question is could francis and
kirill now initiate a conversation
focused on their shared spiritual values
is there ground for one
more inspired hand class between men of
faith
to restore peace
church
and state
now in this negotiation
who is taking the chair
the pope the pope
if they succeed
by reaching into the heart of the
standoff
it could bring us back from the brink
and deliver the second greatest miracle
in modern history
martin i believe the kings of the world
in order to avoid
a nuclear calamity
will have to give their power unto the
peace exactly
and once he has done that what did the
verse say they will set up what
abomination of desolation ah
isn't that what we've been speaking
about for years that's it
so pope in the middle of russia ukraine
crisis he's in the middle the news tells
us he's in the middle
the papacy is back in global politics
that is assuming it ever left
martin this has been a game that has
been coming a long long time
the gesture by pope francis to visit the
russian embassy in rome on friday was
undoubtedly a notable event for a
variety of reasons
the vatican has a centuries-old foreign
service of diplomats and spies
think tanks and journalists
nothing that the pope does is ever
coincidental martin this is the asia
times
it sounds like a
reference from the bible yeah or the
spirit of prophecy
there's also the ponderous vatican
bureaucracy which makes the decisions
for the pope but interestingly
francis's visit to the russian embassy
on friday was not listed in his
customary daily program sheet of
engagements
so
there are negotiations behind the scenes
that alone makes it an extraordinary
hands-on papal gesture that has no
recent precedent the us cable network
cnn reported that the pope spoke with
the russian ambassador for more than an
hour and a half francis has called for
the peaceful end of the conflict and is
urging catholics to set wednesday aside
as a day of fasting and prayer dedicated
to peace in the ukraine
now according to other sources he
actually spoke on the phone
to
putin himself
so is he taking center stage in the
political drama definitely all right so
let's look at catholic culture the
ambassador ukraine would welcome
people visit
vatican mediation to avert war
the payable visit will have a very great
impact for the development of the
situation
and
let's see what they said as i understand
it the vatican would be ready and happy
to create this possibility for meeting
leaders from both sides he added ukraine
is completely in favor of this very
influential
very spiritual place
for a meeting if russia confirms its
will to sit at the table immediately
ukraine will respond in a positive way
so they're all willing so at the moment
it's happening telephonically through
the various embassies
but he's taking center stage
so the pope makes an
unprecedented moves he makes a personal
appeal in remarkable
russian embassy visit pope francis went
to the russian embassy on friday to
personally express his concern about the
war
in ukraine in an extraordinary hands-on
papal gesture
that has no recent precedent
francis later assured a top ukrainian
greek catholic leader he would do
everything i can to help
the head of the ukrainian greek catholic
church the last largest eastern right
church in communion with rome welcomed
francis's protocol bending diplomatic
intervention
and said it hoped it would help dialogue
prevail over force
is the
chef chuk said the pope later phoned him
in kiev and assured him i will do
everything i can
so here we have the church
acting in unison together
using the papacy as the chair
as the seat of the power
as the negotiators
now revelation 17 12 says and the ten
horns which thou sourced are ten kings
which have received no kingdom as yet
but receive power as kings one hour with
the beast
so now this issue of ten horns
if you read the book of revelation the
ten horns
refer to the european powers and its
affiliates
so one of the outflows of the ten horned
powers
is of course the united states of
america and any of the colonies in the
world as well
there's also the other view that it's
the 10 regions in the world
if you stick to the
purely biblical picture
could you read that the christian powers
which thou sourced
which have received no kingdom as yet
receive power as kings one hour
with
the beast
so they will give their power unto the
beast so martin
when they give their power
to the beast there must be some
precedent
that induces them to give that power
unto the beast
because the constitution in the united
states says
that church and state must be separate
what tremendous calamity
could make them say
it is expedient
that we give our power
to the beast to prevent a nuclear war
aha
is that a possibility just a thought i
think it's very possible so who is being
actually defeated
the mindset
which says the church has nothing to do
with the state correct so that's
actually the king of the south that's
the king of the south mindset that has
to go
and the force and the power of it must
be so great
that fear
will be the weapon employed to induce
humanity to embrace it correct
did they do the same on the health issue
yes
isn't it the tactic that works very well
for them working very well we'll get to
that but it's also working on the
climate change issue okay
here's an article from the business
insider where the european commission
chief
says about the ukraine they belong to us
they are one of us and we want them in
they belong to us they are one of us we
want them in von laden told euro news on
sunday
the hill reported on saturday that
zelensky pressed the eu as well as the
north atlantic treaty organization about
ukraine's membership status
asking for a firm timeline van leyen
told euro news that the eu had a process
with ukraine
that includes integrating the ukrainian
market in a single market and close
cooperation on the energy grid
now if the other side says
over my nuclear war body
would that be a reason to give the power
unto the beast as a compromised
situation yes because it will create
fear
putin reveals plan to dominate europe
beyond ukraine neighbors finland and
sweden are also warned they will face
military and political consequences if
they join nato
now those countries are already part of
the european union but they're not part
of nato that's a very interesting
situation so now he's threatening them
there seems to be this pressure from the
putin side
to
change the thinking of the western world
to come more in line with the model
values of the papacy yes
and
if this compromise could be worked and
you could prevent nuclear war
who knows what will happen in the future
maybe china will jump in who knows how
great this pressure will become there's
still there's still another party there
that can be used to ratchet up the
pressure right
russia said if finland and sweden join
nato there will be serious repercussions
that's a warning
yes both of those countries have said
they will ignore what putin is saying
intelligent officials are worried kiev
would fall within days of the intense
fighting
the spokeswoman of putin's foreign
affairs said finland and sweden should
not base their security on damaging the
security of other countries
so they're playing a very clever
political game you know and the other
thing is it sounds
similar to what happened
with hitler and the second world war so
that again brings up this fear that's
being driven
all right what was the response of
finland finland will today debate
joining nato despite threat from
neighbors russia
that they will face military and
political consequences
so they will debate this and they have
reached 50 000 signatories
so if more and more countries want to
join nato
that would give more and more impetus
to the possibility of a
clash
even of a nuclear nature
so we definitely need some kind of
compromise
and modern it's not only finland and
sweden
kosovo
asks the us for permanent military base
and speedier nato membership
kosovo has asked the united states to
establish a permanent military base in
the country and speed up its integration
into nato
after russia's invasion of ukraine
kosovo's defence minister
ahmet mihaj said on sunday
accelerating kosovo's membership in nato
and having a permanent base of american
forces is an immediate need to guarantee
peace security and stability in the
western balkans
said on his facebook page
so it appears as if the pressure is on
russia
and
that nato is making
putin desperate
to the point of being willing to push
the nuclear button
what a perfect situation
to get a new
world order
and as we said the new world order is
not just about economics because the
vatican controls economics anyway
it is about giving the power unto the
beast
and this links on to that verse in
revelation where those kings
get an hour
of rulership with
the beast now button
is this something that has developed now
just suddenly out of the blue
or has this perhaps been on the cards
for a long time no
if you go back this has been coming for
a long time didn't we just read in that
article that the papacy plans long ahead
now in
2015 already
gorbachev
issued a warning
that there could be nuclear war over the
ukraine
this has been planned for a long time
i think they've been sitting at a table
for a very long time
in an interview with the german weekly
news magazine der spiegel 83 year old
former soviet leader mikhail gorbachev
said the crisis in ukraine
could lead to large-scale war in europe
or even a nuclear war we won't survive
if someone loses their nerves in the
current tension
so this is a game plan
this is the game plan
here's an article in the express from
march the 2nd
means war with russia
putin to face full nato power this week
if slaughter not stopped
so is there a threat from nato yes we've
got both threatening each other okay
vladimir putin has been warned nato
could opt to intervene directly in
ukraine
if public pressure to stop the slaughter
of citizens were to grow
further so
this propaganda machine is doing a
tremendous job here
martin
do you think it's possible that some
might think well you know
maybe
russia by itself can still be contained
what if we throw china into the mix
would that be a more scary
scenario definitely what countries would
then be threatened besides europe
asian countries all the asian countries
australia and new zealand would they
also come into the fray then that would
be a pretty universal thing right
so if you could have
this added to the fray
then we are sitting according to the
media and according to the game plan on
a powder keg
that could explode
so emboldened by lack of western aid for
ukraine communist regime declares taiwan
belongs to china
so this is the christian perspective cbn
news in the immediate aftermath of
russia's unprovoked invasion of ukraine
on wednesday china's foreign ministry
made an announcement
the communist regime declared to the
world
that it claims taiwan to be part of
china
the claim is similar to the excuse being
used by vladimir putin as a pretext to
invade and violently take territory away
from
his neighbor
so they have this
backup that the walk would escalate into
a worldwide
scenario
but it's always good to have a little
bit of tongue-in-cheek in there
here's a one of the cartoons that has
come out you're distracting putin from
something very important
says john kerry
and his little sign is very interesting
it says stop
climate change after having altered the
term global warming which just doesn't
wash anymore
because
that scientific scenario has gone out of
the window a long time ago
so they're keeping this in the
background as well as one of the reasons
why you have to follow a particular game
plan
let's just backtrack
climate change is not off the table no
not at all
and it's also part of that discussion
that takes place secretly
associated with a lot of lies at that
particular table where the king of the
north and the king of the south sit and
have their little chats
yes and even putin
signed there and don't put china off if
you go back to those articles they also
in there they're all in there so they've
all signed those particular things
now what is interesting
climate change is also very much part of
the papal agenda
but the papal agenda
is not being followed
let's put it this way the script of the
papal agenda
is not being followed to the letter it
is given lip service but it's not
followed because the secular world
hasn't given their power
unto the beast
and let's check that out
here is the article in the jesuit review
it's very important that these are the
jesuits speaking these are actually the
rulers of the world or nobody wants to
believe it
cop 26 did not go far enough it's time
to take the pope francis approach to
climate change you see the
issue cop 26 climate summit in glasgow
was a tale of two cities one afloat on
bold pledges and new promises
the other sinking under the weight of
greta mania and the chance of blah blah
blah from the followers of the swedish
environmental activist greta turnburg
not even barack obama celebrated or
righteri or a surprise u.s china
cooperation pact could reconcile the
differences
now let's see what the issue was
to better understand the contrast we can
explore another pair of cities paris
where a climate accord was hammered out
in 2005
versus rome
and its body of catholic thought
they reveal vastly different
perspectives on climate change
so do we have two mindsets yes the issue
is the same
climate change that's it
but pope francis's climate agenda has a
moral agenda attached to it his approach
is the one that has to be followed by
the world
but the world is not following it is
that a king of the north king of the
south clash yes
okay
the paris approach has everything
backwards
it began with the scientific data of
global warming and manufactured
elaborate methods to stop it
never pondering the larger question to
what ends
the moral issue
rome or the catholic church begins
rightly by defining life's purpose and
then searches for socio-political
structures
that will get us there
paris asks us to reason our way to
ecological sustainability from an
ideological starting point
of planetary plunder
rome encourages us to use
ignazian spirituality
to seek god in all things while
instructing us that we are all stewards
of the earth
that is a mind-blowing statement
so here we have a moral issue a
religious issue
which the paris accord
excludes
so the paris accord is king of the south
philosophy
here the jesuits are saying that's wrong
we need the moral issue
what morality
ignazi and spirituality
martin isn't that doing an injustice to
the holy covenant
one hundred percent
one is exactly the opposite
that's exactly the opposite this is
salvation by experience and salvation by
works as opposed to salvation
by
grace and justification
by faith
right absolutely so we have an injustice
to the covenant and that is what they
want
but they're not getting it
can they now use the threat of nuclear
war in order to achieve that aim
let's continue
paris expects virtuous behavior from an
anthropological premise
that privileges self-interest and
individual liberty
secular mindset king of the south
philosophy
rome understands that virtue flows from
the pursuit of the common good defined
by solidarity
charity and reciprocity
solidarity
fraternity
did the papacy signed and
signed an accord with islam on this
issue yes
is the orthodox church
on board yes is the protestant world on
board everybody so who's against it only
the king of the south philosophy martin
the king of the south philosophy will
have to go
it's pushing against the king of the
north and the king of the north
according to the scriptures will prevail
okay
rome therefore informs the climate
change challenge on two levels
the epistemological
by properly framing the question and
identifying the root causes of the
problem
and the practical by offering
operational principles upon which
socio-political solutions can emerge the
roman document that most obviously
serves as the counterpoise to the paris
agreement
is laudato si
does that contain
the abomination that causes desolation
yes and it contains the mark of the
beast
which is the abomination of desolation
pope francis instructs us that all
things are connected and that climate
change social injustice and economic
inequality are inextricably linked is
the world economic forum involved
yes so whose side are they on
king of the north
throughout the encyclical francis
explains how i idolatry of the machine
and our unbridled pursuit of
narrow self-interest
crowd out any sense of justice and the
common good
roman catholic social
thinking
has to be introduced into the world do
you remember that book by john robbins
which is called
ecclesiastical megalomania yes remember
that we discussed that on a what's up
prof perhaps people should look at that
again
i'll put the link in again put the link
into it then we can start seeing this
picture forming martin this is a
prophetic picture that is so profound
so if we go to daniel chapter 11 and we
read further from verse 40
and at that time of the end shall the
king of the south push at him
but martin they're sitting at the same
table so this is a historical event
that happened
when the papacy lost its political power
right yes but revelation promises that
it will receive it back
then we are told in the book of
revelation that this clash was also a
north
clash when the papacy lost its power
and that spiritually the king of the
south was egypt
spiritually not literally anymore so we
cannot put it into a literal country
minds
it's mines that are clashing
so
will there be another possible push at
the end yes and the king of the north
shall come against him like a whirlwind
with chariots
that's using a war machine martin
horseman
that's a war machine that's soldiers on
the ground
many ships
that's the economy
and he shall enter into the countries
and shall overflow and pass over
so his mindset is going to win
he has the military of all these
countries at his command
and he's telling you lies and giving you
propaganda to make you believe a certain
scenario
but the agenda behind it has to be
studied in detail
i just want to also say here
we don't know exactly what can happen
there can actually be maybe
some nuclear bloms that goes off
but
the end result will still be exactly
what we've said the whole time no matter
how bad it becomes
the prophecy of the bible will be
fulfilled
and you know martin what is what is a
great possibility
is that
all of these things might happen
and the bible says that the abomination
of desolation will be set up
and then there will come a time of
trouble such as never was
perhaps then
the buttons can be pushed but then it is
too late because it's after the close of
probation
now we also had this terrible warning in
daniel 11 41 you shall also enter into
the glorious land and many countries
shall be overthrown
but these shall escape out of his hand
edom moab and the chief children of
ammon
now those countries are all descendants
of abraham
in other words what it is saying he will
also enter the church even god's church
but many will escape out of the
protestant world out of the religious
systems and they will
join now it's interesting that it also
mentions edom in other words many in the
islamic world
will also come to a knowledge of the
truth at the end and it's already
happening
he shall stretch forth his hand also
upon the countries and the land of egypt
shall not escape he shall
gain victory over the secular mindset
he shall have power over the treasures
of gold and silver he will control the
economy
and over all the precious things of
egypt
in other words
that which was totally separated from
the church will again be part of his
treasury
and the libyans and the ethiopians shall
be at his steps in other words all the
nations
will be in harmony with his thinking
so the king of the south mindset is thus
overwhelmed by a massive final thrust by
the king of the north who employs fear
tactics
which is what we are seeing at the
moment
induced amidst a chaos of wars and
economic chaos the military alliances
forced by the king of the north
serve to force the world to accept a
collective morality which will be
dictated by himself even the very elect
are at risk here
because it's very deceptive that's it it
can swallow you in if you don't
sit back and be an observer
the only way to get involved in this is
to do evangelism
now luke 21 26 says men's hearts failing
them for fear
for looking after those things which are
coming on the earth for the powers of
heaven shall be shaken
so martin if the powers of heaven are
even shaken
then this must have a religious
connotation
right
so what is coming upon the earth is
going to be pretty dreadful but we
cannot stop it
and
if we become involved on the level as
the world is involved we will miss the
picture
a few years ago i gave a lecture and i
referred to two books
and i just briefly want to mention them
again two recent books attempt to
explain the relationship between the
vatican and the united states
each has a different agenda
and thus they reach opposite conclusions
common to both however is a primary
focus on the debate over the legitimacy
of america's war in iraq the two books
are parallel empires the vatican and the
united states two centuries of alliance
and conflict
and against the grain christianity and
democracy war and peace
so these two books discuss basically
this conflict
between the two mindsets
they reach different conclusions and
that's not important right now
but
against the grain is a book by george
weigel who is a very prominent
roman catholic
thinker
cutting against the grain of
conventional wisdom new york times
bestseller george weigel offers a
compelling look at the way in which
catholic social teaching
sheds light on the challenges of peace
the problems of pluralism and the quest
for human rights and the defense of
liberty and he makes a strong argument
that the world should embrace this
morality
and the other book parallel empires the
fascinating and highly relevant history
of the turbulent relationship between
the united states and the holy see
recounted and analyzed by italian
journalist and vatican insider
massimo franco
and
this is what the conclusion is parallel
empires leaves no doubt regarding the
impact that the struggle between these
two great powers
one of secular might
and the other of moral influence has had
on both our history and in today's world
so again
the issue of the moral influence of rome
is central to the debate
and putin mentioned this model dilemma
and there is a possibility of war
if the world does not embrace
a compromise
and that compromise
is in the morality of the papacy yes
here's a quote from testimonies volume 9
spiritual darkness this is a time of
spiritual darkness in the churches of
the world martin have they swallowed a
lie
unfortunately yes because these
propaganda machines are putting all this
forward so they're just swallowing it
and choosing sides so not only have they
followed a false prophetic scenario
which is a jesuitical scenario
this whole issue of rapture and
dispensationalism
and the centrality of a literal nation
when this mindset is a universal war
in every nation and every human mind and
heart
okay so there's spiritual darkness
ignorance of divine things has hidden
god and the truth from view
the forces of evil are gathering in
strength satan flatters his co-workers
that he will do a work that will
captivate the world
while partial inactivity has come upon
the church satan and his hosts are
intensely active
the professed christian churches are not
converting the world
for they are themselves corrupted with
selfishness and pride and need to feel
the converting power of god in their
midst before they can lead others to a
purer or higher standard
they're not going to go higher than the
papal standard no
because that's going to look like the
biblical one so they will miss the point
and they will reject what the reformers
found
and they will embrace a false
science so if we look at what haggy has
to say
then this will become abundantly clear
let's just briefly look at what he had
to say
this may well be the day that historians
look back declaring that this was indeed
the birth of world war iii
history is repeating itself
putin is doing exactly what hitler did
to get world war ii started
hitler declared to european leaders his
need to invade poland
europe failed to respond and the uk
under the leadership of its weak prime
minister neville chamberlain bowed to
hitler's demands iranian threat is real
and iran must be stopped before these
weapons become operational
russia's military has been in the middle
east since 2015.
russia supports iran
iran trains equips and funds the
terrorist armies of hamas and hezbollah
who are begging for the green light to
attack israel with a nuclear weapon
people of america our nation is at a
severe crisis
now is the time to show our strength our
leaders must take their rightful place
at the head of the international table
they must start believing the threats of
our enemies and stop ignoring the plight
of our allies there is a great
responsibility with being a great nation
at this moment we are shirking that
responsibility and abandoning our
greatness if we do not use our freedom
to defend our freedom we will lose our
freedom
martin that was quite a rousing little
speech
and i think many
people in the world will embrace his
point of view
but that would make the western powers
the king of the north and the other
powers the king of the south
but i hope that we have shown that that
cannot be the case
in other words
what he is portraying is the jesuitical
agenda for the end time
events
rather than the biblical agenda where
the papacy
is the beast of revelation chapter 13
and the war is a universal war not
focused on a literal country somewhere
in the middle east
this is actually a false prophetic
picture
which should be set straight yeah all
right martin
so when this king of the north finally
gets what he wants he gets his power
back the mortal wound is totally healed
once again he is the moral heart of
the kings of the world
then we read daniel 11 44 tidings out of
the east not of the north shall trouble
him
therefore he shall go forth with great
fury to destroy and utterly to make away
many
now we've discussed this before the
tidings out of the east
is the warning
against the second coming of christ
the tidings out of the north well he's
the king of the north why is he worried
about the north yes so
there has to be another north there has
to be another north and that north is
the throne of god that's it
so this is the direct intervention of
god in the affairs of men and christ
will return from the east this is the
advent message
the advent message that warns
that the time of his judgment has come
that christ will return and that you
should not accept the mark of the beast
or you will obtain the plagues this will
be especially prevalent
after the close of probation
now has the papacy already voiced
concern about evangelists that use the
media to proclaim messengers such as
these yeah
yes
yes right definitely all right
daniel 11 45 and he shall plant the
tabernacle of his palace between the
seas in the glorious holy mountain yet
he shall come to his end and none shall
help him
it's a rather sad verse right
what you were saying earlier
in during the pandemic if you were
against the norm you were
labeled and
ostracized
now there's laws been written in that if
you go against the narrative
then you are equal to a terrorist
that's a very sad state of affairs
so if we go to daniel 11 45 and we look
at them in the other translations like
the niv or the
or the new king james version it says
he will pitch his royal tents between
the seas at the beautiful holy mountain
yet he will come to his end and none
will help him
and the new king james says he shall
plant his tent of his palace between the
seas and the glorious holy mountain
whereas the king james says in the
glorious holy mountain so he will even
exert his influence within the church of
god
in the final days
this is something
that we should be warned against
so martin we are living in very perilous
times
and i don't know
how others feel but i feel that the
final events are coming to
fruition very rapidly
and this conflict
it's been dragging
and there are certain portrayals of
heroes as we have seen
why because this message
has to come through that we need this
moral mediation
and i believe that the kings of the
world are
on the verge or will be pressurized
to give their power unto the beast which
they've probably done in secret already
just to convince the mindset out there
that this is absolutely necessary for
universal peace
and then when they achieve it
they will shout
peace peace and safety and safety
and what will happen
sudden destruction may god
help us
to reach as many people as we can
with the true gospel
the everlasting gospel
that we cannot give our power unto the
beast and turn our efforts against the
holy covenant
may god help us to set the record
straight let's pray
heavenly father
the world is on the verge of the
greatest deception in the history of
humanity and the result will be
devastating
unless we embrace the truth
and accept the fact that we have to
separate ourselves from babylon
we will be swept away
in the whirlwind that is coming
help us to warn the world
and may you reach through your holy
spirit
all those
that cling to you
that cling to salvation in christ and
christ alone
and believe the scriptures i pray in
jesus name amen
[Music]
you